[Music]  sorry about that so I just was wondering  he just won't do it hello katni have you  have we lost you alright it looks like  Courtney doesn't really want to go there  because she's wasting me I think she's  totally blanking questionably a PR  person they're saying you know don't  talk about it but um this you could just  say sisters five Kourtney Kardashian has  seemingly attempted to avoid talking  about Kim Kardashian's Paris robbery  ordeal on an Australian Morning Show  this week port did eventually start  talking again excusing the blanking as a  bad connection I mean you know she's not  doing great you know I've personally  been taking time to just digest  everything and you know I'm still shaken  up still it is business as usual for  Kourtney we spotted her and mom Kris  back to filming scenes for their show  Wednesday night in LA a source close to  production tells et everyone but Kim is  working on the new episodes  [Music]  you